[Music]
hello and welcome to Ana's trailer
commentaries in the show where we talk
about the show you hopefully just
watched in this case honest trailer for
The Incredible Hulk oh yeah so long
since we started this one we will be
discussing please give it a watch come
back here for our breakdown analysis
thoughts behind the thoughts and if you
stick around to the end some deleted
scenes some cut jokes of that nature or
I think there's like eight people that
just watch this show now I don't know
five weird okay your choice but you do
you enjoy the show here's the thing this
was a when laziness met opportunity yeah
because this is an Australia that we had
done oh us not the movie yeah years ago
now oh yeah it's been off the schedule
for at least two years this has been on
our schedule I will promise you every
time a Marvel movie has come on the
schedule something else is released and
bumps it from the schedule so this has
just been sitting covered in dust and
some creepy attic if you've been to a
convention if you've been to a
convention this was our travel trailer
as we'd show people this one as an
unseen honest trailer yeah as a perk to
get you in the room yeah that said we
finally had the hole to fill and this
was for for infinity more and there was
no other MCU movie that we had that we
could do no black panther isn't out yet
no and we've literally done every other
one released so for the completion in
the 1990s Captain America well if we've
done beyond MCU yeah this is what kept
bumping it off of the list yeah to do
this we did the other whole blade we did
everything for a new Marvel movie we
found another Marvel property yeah it
would be more fun to do I should have
done Howard the Duck and just kept you
know this could just be the Lucy in the
football thing late no too late now so
it's out Incredible Hulk I say all this
preamble to just cover the fact
I haven't seen this movie I remember a
little bit about it and Norton seemed
fine yep there were some better Hulk
effects than the era bana one
Thunderbolt Ross was introduced and
randomly stayed in the MCU but that's
it's weird that he's what's the oh my
god yeah it's it's okay I don't hate
this movie as much as some people hate
it it's okay yeah it's certainly Marvel
like what are we doing yeah are we doing
this okay they're definitely right it's
weird that they still at this point like
think that the only way to do Hulk is
sadboy hitchhikes down the highway and
can't because sad that I mean you've
done it three times at this point you
know like or twice the show he needs
someone to play off of just something
about the character like you're just
waiting for the release of the Hulk 'no
severy time he's not the hulk he's just
like the opposite of drama he's just
trying to be like nonreactive
passive yeah just like staying still and
that's just not compelling there's
nothing more exciting than a guy being
like hey everybody just calls yeah let's
just take a breather yeah I liked this
movie a lot more than I should have when
it came out because at this point the
MCU wasn't full speed ahead and so I was
still getting excited because like the
word Stark was on a truck yeah yeah just
little did bits like that
Oh
who is the guy supposed to be the
comedian who gets he starts Mutai he's
the guy who says leaders you're supposed
to be the leader yeah this was there
setting up and nope no sorry Tim Blake
Nelson yeah the abomination was so on
the nose I wanted like in that moment
for him to be like I could be a leader
enough for one frame they bring back the
Angley comic-book transition yeah so I
don't know anything more to say about
the Incredible Hulk no I love the TV
show and they realized it's the only way
to do the Hulk is to literally reset the
story every way every weight was how
they did it he was you know he was a
journeyman
yeah cuz it's yeah it's either about a
big green monster or a guy waiting to do
yeah Ruffalo did the character a little
better he sure did so let's check out
the honest trailer for the incredible
old oh no I'm in the sinking chair
[Music]
Kampai Marvel Studios and Universal
comes the second movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that we're doing an
honest trailer for because Infinity
Ward's coming out we've already done all
the other MCU movies and black panther
isn't on blu-ray yet The Incredible Hulk
very epic yeah oh so pause obviously we
rewrote the intro yes that we've updated
we did update there's some there are a
two to our credit there are some current
and see you up jokes that we've yes
we've revised this like four times an
update I think it was for Doctor Strange
for yeah before you see dr. strick Civil
War maybe I don't remember yeah we've
rewritten the intro to the name five
times what's those what are we gonna do
now when we when we need to do something
to convention we're gonna have finish
early the Marvel short films yeah the
one shots yeah where Coulson sits at a
gas station really exciting absolutely
in Cannon did they have one where they
tried to like retro actively say the
Mandarin was like a yes like a truck
triple-a they tried to unmanned during
the Mandarin and it definitely counts
they do supposedly they say they're
cannon yeah yep keep going meet Bruce
Banner no not the one people like who's
that he never heard the whole what are
you working no you know the one I'm
talking about death to smoochy guy there
he is
edy Norton shines as the first Marvel
actor to show off how many crunches he
did for the part
and he's bringing his incredible range
to a role that has him act like he's on
xanax I know a few techniques could help
you manage that anger very effectively
while off-camera he's bringing his
incredible ego to a full rewrite of the
script under the fake name Edward
Harrison do you want to get Terrence
Howard it because that's how you get
Terrence Howard it pause this is not the
first time that Norton it's done cuz
Terrence has a very unique collaborator
American History X he was very
apparently hands-on and also with this
movie just meat puppets actors get in
line ya know that I think that there's
two sides to this story because um well
true he does exert a large amount of
influence and control over the projects
he's in I remember reading that Marvel
gave that to him to get him to sign on
to the movie like he was unsure he was
like I don't know if I want to do
whatever like make it your own ad like
it's yours so whatever you like whatever
you wish and then he like rewrote the
whole thing and I'm like oh no I so I do
believe that I'm sure that they kind of
bent over backwards to get someone like
Edward Norton to be in their fledgling
yeah can you imagine if they had kept
him and he still had his creative
control clause like what everything else
would have looked like on through the
MCU maybe something like this yeah
definitely was here's our here's our
painstakingly tight script for the
Avengers and ed Norton's like I don't
think so more shots of Bruce Banner
working in a soda fact yeah yes you know
I know some techniques Captain America
that could really calm you down after
being in man eyes oh yeah poor guy
oh it all shook out the way it should as
we comment on at the end of this trip I
loved I could tell what JT's tired of
our discussion because he's back to the
split screen he's like okay
no he's got great instincts yeah you
weren't wrong not over till 6:30 chewing
brews for a story where he runs away
from the military runs away from the
military
runs away from the military again but
sometimes when his little Fitbit thing
he hits 200 he'll turn into the Hulk an
unstoppable rage monster that's actually
a huge danger to the entire planet the
economy of Brazil simple and bottling
bacteria all Apollo
yeesh I'm glad he flew up to not planet
hog it would mean earth left earth anis
to punch see yes we worked on this
within paltrow took before year ideas
and before natalie portman took an
indefinite absence dumped us mutual
dumping live time without so much as an
easter egg stand and smile as the
actress spends most of the movie
standing and smiling as she doesn't get
anything or even anyone to do i can't
get too excited you've always wanted to
see the Hulk what's that it was kind of
strange that again she was a really good
fit for that part mmm yeah he really did
nothing with her whatsoever
I mean she's yeah the good version of
that is is Hulk and Scarlett Johansson I
guess so yeah but you know the with her
parent I mean the dynamic do the one
thing I was built for make babies yeah
okay I take i rescind my comment she's
just there's like a piece of something
for for the Hulk to lust after and it
shows that they weren't quite sure
exactly how everything fit into this
puzzle that they also didn't know they
were making yeah really did a little bit
but not really no it wasn't until after
Thor worked that they were like oh we
can do anything
delete it up all right fine full speed
ahead
yeah let's go yeah bring her back though
well she is a is the voice no no not her
she's not the the other Betty from
angley's is Jennifer Connelly yeah I get
my Betty's crossed so many Betty's but
no I still think yeah it is a little
surprised I guess they kind of wash
their hands it but then they brought
William Hurt back yeah so it's like well
did they then I don't
whatever it's all very confusing I was
like I like Tyler so say she's a good
actress and I wish that they would have
found a place for her solely and if they
did things does some kind of like
reality gem and there's like infinite
hulks and infinite Betty's I hope they
bring everyone yeah we get that happy
ending the abomination does get
mentioned again in one of the Marvel
one-shots which absolutely count yeah
yeah if there was like like a friends
type sitcom with three hulks and three
Betty's but it was all the three hulks
and well to Betty's and I ScarJo
I'd watch that sounds like it's the
kindest card you get equal his powers
well too bad because he's fighting the
skinny British guy from Reservoir Dogs
he's a decorated veteran with zero
personal connection to Bruce Banner and
0ts unlike is completely another story
who shoots himself full of tainted
Captain America juice he'll turn into
one of the most forgettable monsters in
the MCU the mixture could be an
abomination he got his ass kicked all
the way the Batman V Superman I know
it's got a big pop at Comic Con go back
to the day speaking of Marvel had this
whole universe thing avocado 2014 Bears
would only get little taste of
fanservice a sequel was only widely
employed instead of blatantly setting up
five more movies put its post-credit
scene before the credits the photos that
we were putting a team together and
didn't make a billion dollars
oh that's like Green Lantern money
uh-uh no I know what it's like not about
expectations so strap in for this odd
sequel Requa reboot origin movie that's
better than we give it credit for
because whatever you think about the
film itself
it gave us Mark Ruffalo cleaner job and
paved the way for Ed Norton to join Wes
Anderson's fancy boy Cinematic Universe
oh man I cannot wait for the Royal
Tenenbaums to fight Steve Zissou in
Budapest hotel infinity floor
okay Green Goblin nobody pushes out
Flash Thompson in this quirky hotel and
gets away with it it's very late in the
game that was in fact the Green Goblin
punching enough time lion every actor
will be part of a Marvel movie that's
true yeah we tweaked around the edges
and Laurie really we just wanted to give
a shout out to Tony Romo Laurie Tony
Rosa
yeah so we cobbled together oh it's not
over yet is it is it over
I am Jack's departure due to creative
differences
Iggy Pop like a Ross y'all got an Iron
Man suit that he's voicing had she
doesn't heroin no disposable
now she can't import Amala yeah it's
probably not the first time a white guy
got so hammered in Brazil he woke up
half-naked in Guatemala Spring Break 97
whoo Oh John shut it out a couple of his
Spring Break yes he's got wildlife like
character yeah windows into it he's
honest trailers whoof it's tough yeah
yeah we should make that short film the
epic voice guy super cut like not
charlie
epic voice yeah two different people yes
compiling they're different you could
use painting that really sad portrait of
use the sad hold music forum yeah good
so deleted scenes maybe maybe there's
something in there do we have deleted
scenes sure okay let's watch our are
from Marvel and Universal whoa
that dates this comes the green headed
step child of the MCU they came out just
three months after Iron Man and was
forgotten just as quickly the Incredible
Hulk
no one takes this is part of AMC
literally the only way to justify the
Hulk is to make him fight evil aliens
and this guy be oh and probably don't
give him any more solo movies and she
doesn't even get hulk smashed for her
trouble how would hug smash I mean talk
about blue balls who doesn't maybe
they're green balls wouldn't start a
support group with Superman that thing
rogue and cyborg or an orgy mmm but yeah
there is something about there's some
worry pause for a second there's so many
superhero virgins they can't do it it's
Captain America yeah Superman
[Music]
well not the Christopher Reeve Superman
dude no what they do yeah I mean I'm
just making assumptions there but it
didn't seem like their first time in the
tub no yeah well the thing did have a
wife beforehand so never mind that joke
doesn't work joke does it well it's
really just kind of CAP and rogue yeah
cuz Chris Evans now Plus jokes mr.
Buckey stuff and that has been bucking
around a year and a half old we're like
yeah green balls or blue balls so many
times I think you're kind of like the
best we can do no it's not
well let's see what else we cut hooray I
must ask you a question can helicopter
parent is in a helicopter looks like a
lady well that's the bag literal
abomination
the incredibly forgettable Hulk cuz her
name was Meghan the leftover she was
like the main villain on the leftover
right deep leftovers cut well not deep
but Meg is a shark shark movie shark
movies you guys said make it relevant
again bringing it up to date which we
sort of did now that we've held back the
curtain it might look a little bit more
like a horrible Frankenstein monster
stitched together out of spare jokes and
two-year-old jokes you ever just had
something you made two years ago stare
you in the face there you go there you
go you know what sometimes I wouldn't
call it a week off no but we're working
actually more yes this was deferred to
long deferred gratification
we worked hard many years ago to bring
you this small nugget of joy today we
have to do a Doctor Who trailer now so
that yeah we're gonna we got a bias but
rolling out as we go like wave like
downhill from here
just blame doctor it's because we're
watching Doctor Who so much doctor yeah
cuz we're timey wimey sleepy-weepy
crappy flappy stuff yeah that's all
we're gonna get out of the Hulk its long
journey has finally come to an end US
10-year long yeah journey brought it
right here to die at the footsteps of
Mary hope he makes it out of infinity
more so we can make more health jokes
let's go let's go hitchhike in the rain
on a highway guys alright next week
thanks our special oh yeah Oh our first
fundraiser trailer if I'm not mistaken
there you go that's good
you
[Music]